中国机器人公司的竞赛
已经到了白热化的阶段
从春晚的舞台合作到机器人马拉松
再到各种融资新闻
如今 连机器人出海赛道也火热起来了
魔法原子带着顶流艺人张艺兴
邀请到了图灵奖得主
及众多机器人行业大咖
直接把产品发布会开到了硅谷
魔法原子是中国机器人行业中
近来讨论声量不小的一家公司
它是由小米铁蛋的研发班底起家
之后借着全链生态和全球渠道迅速崛起
成立两年之后
魔法原子的机器人熊猫借着春晚火爆出圈
而就在这时
突然传出前总裁吴长征离职等消息
引发外界的讨论和猜测
我们对这家公司的好奇点在于
机器人赛道为什么会在这么初期
就在中国市场有如此激烈的竞争
真的可以商业化落地了吗
中国机器人公司们发展的路径
是如何选择的
以及各家的“护城河”究竟在哪里
国内的机器人公司主要在本体
你同意这个说法吗
为什么大家会觉得说
中国人永远做不出脑子
肯定不是这样的
中国公司我们从出身第一天开始
更加关注我是不是能够比较快地
具备一些自我造血的能力
1.5亿人民币的一个超大订单
具体客户都是谁
他们为什么要去订购
导览 文娱表演 巡检或者搬运
这样子的一些基础的工作
是一阶段落地的场景
二阶段的话
可能我们在整体工业和商业场景下
它会有更强的泛化能力
更长远一些走的话 家庭场景下的
出错容忍度极低的这些具体场景
现在中国的机器人公司们
会进入价格战吗
你觉得它是一个良性的竞争
还是它会诞生一些泡沫在里面
你有没有听到批评说
中国的机器人公司
花太多的钱在营销跟广告上了
国内整个大众对于AI具身智能
这方向上的热情是空前高涨的
营销费用这件事情
其实纯看绝对值 是没有太大意义的
最近刚完成了新一轮的5亿元的新融资
我们现在已经在进行新一轮的融资了
太快了 现在全市场都差不多是这样
我知道前段时间公司的高层
是有一些人员变动的
你接替了总裁的这个位置
我需要保证我们整体的组织能力
是非常灵敏的
是能够快速去调整的
IPO是你接下来的目标之一吗
可能2027年有一个比较明确的上市消息
以下就是我与魔法原子总裁顾诗韬的对话
Polly你好 欢迎做客《硅谷101》
茜老师你好 很高兴认识你
非常开心在硅谷见到你
你们这一行来到硅谷的目的是什么
然后有什么样的消息
想要带给硅谷这边的AI公司
或者机器人公司
我们在4月28号
在Santa Clara举办了
魔法生态的首届全球具身智能创新大会
我们作为一家中国
有比较强的中国基因的企业
我们希望能够在Physical AI（物理人工智能）
这个概念最稠密的地区
包括技术创新爆发速度最快的
像硅谷这个地方
能够去发出一些中国企业
在Physical AI上面的理解
然后发出一些我们自己的声音
也能借由在硅谷的这个平台
快速地去达成一些
产业链上下游的一系列连接
包括可能起到我们对于未来十年的
具身智能产业一些方向上的探讨
也希望能够跟大家有更多的交流
我看市场上有一种声音
说硅谷的公司主要聚焦在大脑
国内的机器人公司主要在本体
你同意这个说法吗
我觉得是这样的
就是看中国市场和美国市场
到底有什么样的比较优势
或者说哪些资源禀赋相对是更密集的
我觉得这里其实更多的是
全球供应链或者产业链分工的一个概念
所以比如说中国市场
我们看到有什么样的一些比较优势
像你刚刚提到的本体对应的
我可能更多的是一些供应链能力的优势
工程化能力的优势
我们另外还有一个非常有价值的优势
来自于我们所谓的数据引擎
就数据燃料
一个非常低成本的获取能力
这也是 比如说今天魔法原子
我们也有自己的数采工厂
我们会看到 国内和海外的客户
有大量真实数据采集的需求
那我们在数据工厂里面
一条有效数据的采集成本
可能能够达到美国采集成本的五分之一
甚至十分之一
这里面非常低廉的生产力成本
以及非常快速的数据采集获取能力
为什么大家会觉得说
中国人永远做不出脑子
肯定不是这样的
其实看到国内 我们现在有非常多的
具身智能行业里面的从业者
大家其实也在非常长期主义地
布局整个的运控也好 交互也好
或者说是大的操作模型
包括我们VLA模型 世界模型也好
其实大家都在这个方向上
有长期的一些布局和长期的战略定力
我们看到 中美双边都有各自的一些优势
你觉得供应链这件事情重要吗
还是说因为中国的供应链已经非常成熟了
所以供应链不能构成一个绝对的“护城河”
我问这个问题也是想问一下
魔法原子怎么去构建你们的供应链
以及上下游的生态
我觉得是这样的
当前中国的人形机器人的供应链
现在还在一个前期布局的阶段
其实还没有大规模地放量
我认为整个量产生产的优势
短期是能够形成一定壁垒的
但非常长期来看 大概率会被拉齐
未来人形机器人这个产业链
它一定会有分工的
现在为什么大家全栈去做闭环
是因为所有东西都没有收敛的情况下
我需要自己有一个全栈式的技术
这样才能支持我保持敏捷作战能力
能够基于终端用户需求
快速地去迭代我的产品
等最终我们产品的形态开始收敛
然后我交付的场景开始收敛
整体行业标准规则都开始制定的时候
其实我们一系列的设计、生产、制造能力
就可以慢慢地去外化给
我产业链上下游的更多的合作伙伴
我观察到一个非常有意思的现象
硅谷这边的公司
我发现他们都比较地垂直在一个应用
或者是一个产品上面
比如说在工业上面
Agility就是一个代表
比如说在家庭 家居等方面
可能1X、Figure AI
还有特斯拉的Optimus
都是比较2C
比较来家庭使用的场景
软件方面的 算法方面
比如说Physical Intelligence还有NVIDIA
都是专注在这个方面的
但我看中国公司非常有野心
什么都做
产品的布局也有很多
从机器狗到小一点的机器人
到大一点的机器人
还有世界模型 这些大家都做
为什么会中美有这样
不同的发展路线跟布局呢
感觉中国真的是在布局一个全栈的生态链
我认为是这样的
更多的其实是出于双边的基础业态
包括商业模式上的选择
我觉得从最宏观的角度来讲
双边在营商环境上是有非常大的区别的
可以看到 整个中国市场
不管是资金的流动性也好
或者说一二级市场资本的容忍度也好
这个我可能讲得就比较直接一些
从投资人的角度来讲
国内市场的人民币的投资人
由于我们可能LP的一些
风险偏好上面的顾虑
所以会导致说 相当一定比例的投资人
他会比较关注未来的退出
然后资金收益的确定性
包括整个商业模式的确定性和稳定性
因此其实可以看到
过往非常长的一段时间里面
中国公司在每一个偏向于前沿的应用领域
会比较关注是不是能够阶段性的
有一些商业化落地的成果产生
因此中国公司从出身第一天开始
我们需要去思考的一个很关键的事情是
我如何在相对比较有限的资源基础之上
能够持续地保证我长期的
技术的旺盛的生命力
以及保证我长期的资金安全性和可靠性
所以在这个方向上
对于中国企业来讲 我们会相对更加关注
我是不是能够比较快地
具备一些自我造血的能力
看到一些阶段性的商业化落地的可能性
接下来我们讲讲具体的产品和具体的需求
能不能跟我们讲一下
魔法原子现在整个产品矩阵是什么样子的
因为这次你们也会发布一个新的机型
能不能帮我们梳理一下Z1 GEN1还有X1
还有你们这个MagicDog的系列
分别是主打什么样的场景
目标是具体什么样的商业落地
我们现在有两条比较标准化的产品线
包括一条人形机器人的产品线
和一条四足机器狗的产品线
可以看到 在过去的几年里面
我们基本上摊出来了一些
相对比较明确的终端用户的画像
比如说GEN1
它更多的是承担了一些技术摸高的职能
就我们那个全尺寸的人形机器人
因为它差不多是1.7米的身高
大概70公斤的一个体重
包括我们传感器的配置
末端灵巧手的配置
我们尽量让它非常近似于一个成年人
整体外观的构造
我们对它的期待是未来它真的能够
实现我们所谓“通用”的
人形机器人的能力
具备非常强的一些通用模型的泛化能力
包括我们这次也会发布自己的世界模型
我们大量的世界模型上的一些应用的落地
我会基于这款全尺寸的人形机器人
来去做进一步的一些探索
小的Z1 就高动态的机器人产品
相对来讲它自由度会少一些
整体差不多是1米35的身高
它目前是承担了大量的 像文娱表演的
教育
包括教育 对
像你说到的 有很多的
因为我们整体有一系列的
SDK开发的工具包
所以整体二次开发的生态
做得是相对比较完善的
第一是作为教具
第二是作为我们拓展自己生态合作伙伴的
一个比较好的载体
能够进一步衍生出来整个魔法原子的生态
这是我们对于Z1的定义
可以看到四足狗条线 我们现在是有两款
一款是MagicDog 是小款的
那个就叫MagicDog
另外一款我们有个Magic的Y1
就是我们工业级的那个大狗
今年的话 我觉得也可以剧透一下
我们今年还会再发一系列的
比如说中等尺寸的四足狗产品
可以看到 四足狗这个品类
它其实相对来讲已经形成了一些
比较稳定的
长期存在的具体的终端需求
它一部分可能在2C方向
一部分在2B方向
2B方向也可以看到
它有一系列会有那种非常高负载的需求
这种的话 我们一般就会用Y1去满足
我们Y1的那个工业大狗
最高负载是可以达到200公斤
所以它其实可以去在一些严寒 包括山地
一些人类很难背负上去的具体的场景
去实现一些特种作业的需求
可以看到还有一些
比如说我们小B级别的一些行业客户
它会有一些像比如说国家电网
或者说一系列工业场景的客户
它会有巡检 安防
包括有一些救援 灭火等一系列需求
这些的话 我们可能就会用
稍小尺寸的工业级的四足狗
来去支持他们的需求
另外 我们在2C的产品线上
基于当前这个MagicDog
我们未来可能还会再出一些
相对来讲价格带更下探
相对更轻量化的产品
这些的话 它未来会更加具有亲和力
你也说到魔法原子很看重国际市场
那对于机器人出海这样的一个赛道
你觉得在国际上的客户画像
跟在中国的客户画像有什么不一样吗
不同的区域会有比较明显的区别
比如说整个亚洲市场会更相似一些
日韩市场的客户需求跟中国市场会很相似
包括新加坡市场也是同理的
基本上国内火什么
我在日韩、新加坡就卖什么
比如说卖文娱的 科研教育的
一定的巡检的 大狗的那些巡检需求
欧洲市场相对比较特殊一些
因为欧洲整个
包括像德国、英国、西班牙这些地方
可能以德国、英国为主
尤其是德国 制造业的基因非常强
而且 我们确实有一些德国客户
他们在过去的十年之间
由于油改电的这波浪潮
是有非常强的失落感的
有大量的一些油车供应链上的企业
它确实经历了一些 比如说GMV的锐减
包括它整个的市场
全球工业老牌的王者地位的回落
所以在这个过程当中
心态上有比较大的落差
所以可以看到我们有很多欧洲客户
非常重视这一波具身智能的浪潮
对他们来讲
它会变成一个我是不是还能留在牌桌上
我是不是能够恢复往日荣光
一个很重要的战略级的定位
美国这边的话
当前还是科研为主
大量的科研经费涌到了具身智能的实验室
大家基本上每个实验室里面
各种类型的机器人产品都至少配置几台
所以我觉得当前这个旺盛增长的需求
尚且没有被填补满
然后进一步 我们可能在美国市场
我觉得各方面都是可以探索的
包括工业场景的 还有包括家庭场景
家庭场景我们可能线上线下
都会同时去布局
看看 比如说我们的四足狗
或者说小人形的产品
是不是能够取得比较好的市场反馈
另外比如说像工业场景
考虑到美国市场导入工业
其实需要一些比较强有力的经销商渠道
他跟当地具体的垂直的一些工业场景
长期有非常稳定的友好关系
因为真的进到2B行业
比如说进到物流行业里面
他其实不太能接受有一个很新的
从来没有见过的一个上游供应商
直接去给他做生产交付的
这个是不现实的
所以我们也是两个方向
第一 比如说纯进到本土化的
一些美国场景
那我们可能通过一些长期的
比较重要的战略合作伙伴
或者经销商的合作伙伴去推进
另外一部分 我觉得很有价值的一点
其实是来自于
跟着我们中国的合作伙伴一起去出海
这是一个比较确定的需求
全球范围内 我觉得不同的区域
它会呈现出一些非常有区别性的诉求
包括对应给到他们产品的形态也好
或者说终端的客户也好 也会有区别
我看到有报告说 你们4月份
获得了1.5亿人民币的一个超大订单
能不能详细跟我们说一下
扒开看一看
每一款机型的订单分别是什么样子的
是什么样的百分比
我问这个问题主要是想大概了解一下
具体客户都是谁
他们为什么要去订购
比如说大量的 每个渠道不同的
这种形态的产品
一个是产品落地的场景
第二个是我产生商业化收入
第三个是我这个1.5亿的订单来源
我觉得可能是这三个问题
我分开来回答
第一个 对于场景落地的
阶段性的速度上面来讲
会看到 我们目前最快能够落地的
一定是相对 比如说半结构化的场景
可以看到 在二阶段的话
我们在整体工业和商业场景下
它会有更强的泛化能力
整体就是在操作层
能够实现的工种会越来越多
可能开始有了一些比如说锁付能力
包括一些穿针引线的能力
它更多地涉及到
灵巧手层面的一些灵巧操作
可能在商业场景下它会有更多的一些
类似于全能售货店员的定位
再往更长远一些走的话
比如说家庭场景下的
相对来讲 对于出错容忍度极低的
这些具体场景
包括整体环境非常杂乱 很复杂
对于模型的泛化能力需求
非常非常高的一些场景
可能是工业也有可能是家庭
我觉得整个场景落地
它一定是遵从这个一 二 三阶段落地的
一个整体的流程
从实际订单来源的角度来讲
反而是有一点区别的
现在一阶段
我们能够拿到的比较确定性的订单
主要还是集中在偏向于交互的一些场景
比如说导览导购、文娱表演
还有从去年开始
全行业都在做数据基建
所以对应的在数采工厂的一系列设备
包括我整机的产品交付过程当中
其实也有一定的收入来源
我们除了短期的一些销货之外
当下现阶段非常重要的一个战略规划
就是把握住我们这些2B的
行业级的标杆级客户
跟他们长期形成非常强黏性的
背靠背的信任的客户关系
然后通过这些2B的行业客户的高度绑定
未来能够埋伏我们
可能不久的将来两年 三年之后
全市场有一个爆发式增长的时候
那个时候魔法原子
我希望 在市场全行业里面
属于一个市占率比较领先的优势位置
到第三阶段的时候
我们做的是一个什么样的竞争呢
更多的时候我们开始比拼的是
战略能力 组织能力
包括资源的调度能力
它会变成越来越像一个商业化的竞争
它会越来越像商战
那个时候我认为可能几点
一个是品牌能力 第二是生态能力
第三个是组织的快速反应能力
它更多的是变成了一个组织工程
或者说系统工程
那个时候 我认为对于魔法原子
或者我们所有创业的人形机器人公司来讲
我们可能会碰到的敌手
我觉得反而是
比如说像华为 小米 或者特斯拉
这样子本身具备非常强的系统能力的企业
我们现在要做的事情是说
在成熟市场来临之前
我们能够把魔法原子这个品牌
非常快速地形成大众的品牌认知
我认为现在可能在全球市场
也就不到百亿人民币的一个状态
我们说这个还为时尚早
但是我认为 目前看到中国
包括硅谷的整体人形机器人
模型迭代的速度
我认为这个市场爆发式增长的拐点
不会来得太晚
它可能就是在2029年 2030年
那时候留给我们的时间窗口
也就大概三四年的时间
这三四年的时间里面
我们要快速地去锻造和锤打出一套
我能够直接PK可能10万名员工的
一个大的组织体系的能力
我觉得在这方面
谁先想清楚这件事情
并且更早地去把整个组织能力搭建起来
其实是能够更快地把握这个先机
并且未来能够抵御一些潜在的
来自于更多大厂下场的风险
我认为 这个在三阶段
三阶段整体商业模式上的一些思考
现在也必须要开始布局了
我觉得过去两年我能够感觉到
中国公司的竞争变得越来越激烈了
你觉得现在的竞争主要是发生在哪一层
可能第三层还没到
我觉得现在应该是在1.5层的样子
对于应用场景的拓展
包括对应用场景的覆盖
上一个阶段可能2024 2025年的时候
大家还在主要专攻运控
更多是走得漂亮 跑得漂亮
我觉得 其实我们很早
2025年年初的时候
我们就开始讲上肢的灵巧操作
我的Manipulation（操控）的算法能力
甚至我们当时提出来说
我们当时做的双层的解耦模型
就是VLA模型（视觉语言行动模型）
上层是一个VLM的模型（视觉语言模型）
我去做二次开发
下层是一个MoE的混合专家模型
这个它也具备比较强的泛化能力
这个混合专家模型
它可以去实现一些比较具体的垂直场景
或者说半结构化场景的具体需求
这整个双层结构模型
相对来讲 对数据的需求量
预训练和后训练
没有预训练的部分 就后训练的部分
对数据的需求量相对就能大大地降低
同时我整体模型交付的周期也会相对缩短
这些是能够比较好地先行进到工业场景
能有不错的模型效果水平
我觉得今年以来
我看到很多厂家也开始反应过来了
在整个工业场景落地层面
更加加紧地去做更多的尝试
我觉得这也是好事
你觉得现在中国的机器人公司们
会进入价格战吗
还是说太早了
短期其实不太会
我觉得这个可能跟大家以为的还有点区别
工业场景就不提了
因为工业场景现在大家更多
我的B端的客户
第一他卡ROI（投资回报率）他确实会卡
所以他的ROI（投资回报率）会决定
他对于产品形态的选择
我举个例子
比如说他就会觉得
你足式的人形现在进到我的工厂里面
没有必要
我要一个轮式底盘的人形产品
我可能成本能降三分之二
同时又不影响它具体的一些巡检 搬运
甚至一些灵巧操作需求的实现
这种他就会比较偏好一个轮式底盘产品
但是他绝对不会直接考核
说今天公司A的轮式底盘产品
跟公司B的轮式底盘产品
可能价格上面差了20%
他就会选择那个便宜20%的产品
一定不是这样的
他在那个时候考核的
就是大家整体模型交付的能力如何
包括这个过程当中
是不是有比较好的稳定性
是不是不太有很多的售后问题
包括它的整体
比如说我的泛化能力
不要最后搞的都是一堆规则算法
那就没有意思了
所以是不是能够很好地支持
他们一些产线上的柔性生产
这个是B端客户考虑的问题
因为对他来讲
如果40万的产品跟20万的产品
那是产品本质上的一些区别
但大家都在20万价格带
大家比拼的其实就是产品能力了
所以不管是在文娱还是教育
还是说工业场景
我认为完全没有到打价格战的这个阶段
因为目前还不是
那你觉得现在大家技术差得多吗
因为刚才我们已经说到
我觉得中国的机器人公司都很卷
不管是谁出了一个新的产品或者新的技术
其他家跟得也很快
模型上面 不管是VLA还是世界模型
大家最近发布得也都非常集中
然后在尺寸跟产品上
大家也都做机器狗 都做小的产品
也都做1.7米的机器人
但我看上去整个的技术栈跟产品栈
都是比较趋同的
这么两百多家公司
最后如果能够跑出来的赢家
你觉得一定要有的优势或者“护城河”
是什么样子的
它是技术绝对的领先性
还是人才密集度的领先性
是什么决定了最后
谁变成这个市场的赢家呢
我觉得是这样的
目前在市场上看到百花齐放的一个状态
每家各自的侧重点也不同
战略方向都是有区别的
有一些是偏向软件更多
有一些是偏向硬件更多
所以我们要解答的问题可能是说
你怎么看待这个行业的终局
现在大家都不太确定行业终局是什么样子
所以我觉得
底层如果一定说有一个什么样的能力
是决定长期的企业的竞争优势
我认为是对终端场景的覆盖和理解能力
我觉得这个是能够保持企业长期竞争力的
非常重要的一个来源
我需要确保的是
我永远有一个非常强的
中后端技术的和产品的团队
能够支持我终端的任何一个场景
爆发出来的可能性的一些需求的增长
所以我们在底层做一些资源的配置
包括我们沉淀下来一些软件和硬件的
中台沉淀下来的基础能力
这种是我能够去复制到
我所有的一些细分产品线的
其实不止你们一家在出海
当海外的客户看到
这么多中国公司在出海的时候
你觉得他们对于采购的一些
最终决定因素是什么
当中国机器人公司都在出海的时候
什么决定了大家能卖多少
我觉得这也是为什么
我们很坚定要做全球化的一个原因
快速地在本地去完成本土化的团队搭建
这里的本土化团队搭建
包括不限于我们本地化的销售团队
法务的团队 售后支持的团队
甚至我们可能还会有一些门店的员工
这些能够支持我们
快速地通过海外本土化的品牌形象
去积累海外的一些用户认知
至于说具体哪个场景
哪个国家区域的客户
他们对应的关注机器人的什么能力
刚刚我觉得基本也分享得差不多了
美国、欧洲客户偏好都有区别的
欧洲客户 工厂客户居多
他肯定就是看我实际的作业能力
准确度到底怎么样
包括完成这个作业的时间不能太久
两分钟做一个 他就受不了
比如说美国客户 他可能就更加关注
因为我卖的都是一些科研教育场景
做二次开发的
所以他会更关注售后的能力
包括我这个二次开发的亲和力
比如说像日韩的 新加坡的客户
他就会关注我的交互到底做得怎么样
是不是能有一些
比如说在开放场景
很空旷的场景下的一些定向识别
人跟我会话的能力
包括是不是有比较强的
一些多机群控的能力
能够实现比较漂亮的一些
大规模集群的舞台表演
各个区域 国家地区的客户
他的诉求会不太一样
好 再回到中国市场的竞争上面来
我觉得还挺有意思的
因为很多人会觉得说
现在机器人发展还是一个比较初期的阶段
没有想到中国公司已经这么卷了
而且都开始卷落地了
这样的卷 你是怎么看的
你觉得它是一个良性的竞争
还是它会诞生一些泡沫在里面
我觉得卷肯定是良性的
代表着这个行业里面
首先受到的关注变多了
可以看到国内整个大众对于AI、具身智能
这方向上的热情是空前高涨的
在整个 我觉得整个相对经济
比较波动的一个状态下
一个AI 一个具身智能是比较少见的
能够点燃大众热情的一些
确定性的 非常积极的方向
在这种积极方向上 我们对应的
能够吸收到大量的资金资源
以及最优秀的人才
能够快速地加速这个行业往前发展
就可以看到 三年前的行业
跟今天的这个行业完全不可同日而语
确实过去两年
强化学习整体在运控上面的表现
都非常惊艳
各家都能看得出来
大家能力迭代得都非常快
所以我觉得 这种快速之间的角力
是能够推动大家快速地去做技术层面
包括产品层面的一些创新的
大家拼的是什么
甚至有的时候拼的是勤奋
拼的是意志力
还有拼的是长期的一些战略眼光
所以在这种 基本上人就处在一个
精神上面相对比较紧张的状态
我觉得这个是好事
因为大家在不断地去
可能在超越自己的极限
包括在快速地去迭代和优化
自己的组织能力的过程里面
我们会看到 三年前人形机器人行业
可能很多时候是小打小闹的
我们可能很多
并不是非常科班出身的“杂牌军”
可能实验室的一帮子人做出来这个产品
可能就已经是人形机器人行业的代表了
但是到2025年 2026年
我们会看到 比如说上次机器人马拉松
荣耀的那个产品
它那个特种的机器人产品
就纯散热 散热做得比较好
跑得也非常快
就会看到越来越多的成熟行业里面的
非常头部的玩家也开始下场去做了
所以它给整个行业
我觉得标准在快速地提升
所以这是一件很好的事情
在这个过程当中一定
我作为这中间参与的一个比较微观的单元
我也是这200家企业之一
你要说有没有压力
我觉得肯定是有压力的
但是我觉得对应的其实也是
我们一个生态和平台型公司长期的底气
就比如说未来这个行业里面
真的开始经历一些聚合的事件
开始有一些“马太效应”
或者说有少数企业的清退
我觉得肯定会有
在这个清退的过程当中
我只要关注魔法原子
是在一个什么样的定位上面就可以了
你有没有听到批评说
中国的机器人公司花太多的钱
在营销跟广告上了
特别是在一个行业的初期
你怎么看这样批评的声音
因为包括 不管是我们看到春晚
还是看到最近的机器人马拉松
其实都是各家公司花了很多的营销费用
你怎么去看这个营销费用的ROI
怎么去看它值还是不值呢
我觉得这个是各家企业
自己的一些战略决策
我这里不做过多评价
但是如果我们去看
我觉得营销费用这件事情
纯看绝对值是没有太大意义的
更多的我们可能要看它的相对比例
我不知道其他家什么样
比如说针对魔法原子来讲
我们的营销费用 它整体的占比
一定是远低于我的研发费用支出的
我觉得这个对于机器人公司来讲
长期 我真的把它作为一个
可销售的商品的时候
它需要具备的一定能力
这个能力
它可能前期需要花费一些营销费用
或者品牌费用
我觉得这个也未尝不可
整体从魔法（原子）的角度来讲
一定是把它放在一个比较可控的状态
并且一定是维持我长期的
大量的研发投入不动摇的
你们最近刚完成了新一轮的5亿元的融资
这代表着接下来多久的一个运行窗口
以及接下来你们重点押注点
是在哪些方向
是这样 我们5亿的融资
其实春节之前基本就交割了
我们现在已经在进行新一轮的融资了
太快了
现在全市场都差不多是这样
大家都在储备一些“粮草”
所以新一轮融资估计也会比较快的时间
可能一个月之内还会有新一轮的交割
我们在去年年底的时候
也开启募集了自己的生态基金
首期是20亿人民币的规模
这支生态基金
现在也已经开始是一个在投的状态了
它会帮助魔法原子进一步去夯实整个生态
产业链体系里面的打造
5亿能花多久
我觉得我们倒不太会思考这个问题
因为我认为一个优秀的企业
可能是有多少花多少的企业
有多少钱我就办多少事
它可能能够成就出一个比较优秀的公司
但是怎么能成就一个伟大的公司
一定是我先定了我的目标
我再去思考要达成这个目标
我需要多少资源
所以我觉得魔法原子一定是后者
今天我们想做的事情是说
我们可能想做中国第一
我们既然来到硅谷
我也希望未来能够跟Optimus Figure
有一战之力
我们想去达成这样子一个
宏大愿景的前提条件
是我优秀的技术能力
我非常强的产品能力
包括我的供应链 量产能力的打造
包括我自己的生态朋友圈
我怎么跟着国内的客户一起出海
它里面会拆解出来大量的
战略和策略上的小的执行方向
对应这些小的执行方向
对应的我要铺人
我要有前期一些算力的投入
数据采集的一些投入
这些它对应的会有大量的耗费
我其实思考的是说
我达成每一个里程碑之前
大概这些对应的耗费需要多少资金
我对应的这些资金
至少可能要提前12到18个月
为我的公司储备这些资金
才能够快速地去促使公司往前发展
这个我们可能更多是一个需求拉动的状态
我们希望公司能够在未来很短的时间里面
快速地去跃迁到国内第一
甚至全球第一的声量
我能感觉到你们公司发展得非常快
你觉得公司的组织架构
能跟上这样的速度吗
我问这个问题是因为
我知道前段时间公司的高层
是有一些人员变动的
之前的吴总他离开了公司
然后你接替了总裁的这个位置
当然市场上有一些猜测
借这个机会能不能请您跟我们分享一下
他离职的具体原因是什么样子的
可以 我觉得这个问题还蛮好的
因为过去市场上也看到很多
并不是很真实的猜测 包括风言风语
我觉得也正好借这个机会
做一下整体事实的还原
我们经过了一些比较友好的协商
长征出于个人和家庭的考虑
也确实希望休息一段时间
再看看 可能短暂的
先阶段性地离开魔法原子
当时长征离职之前
我们也都比较深入友好地做过交流
包括后期 如果长征他个人有创业的想法
或者说有其他更多的打算
我们也都会支持的
包括 如果未来长征还有想法
说回到魔法原子
去做其他的一些新方向上的创业或者考虑
我觉得也都完全欢迎
如果我们去打个比喻
说魔法原子是在水上航行的一艘船
我的角色更多的是那个造船的人
造船的人 我负责的是什么
更多的是 也分向外和向内
向外的话 确保足量的资金 足量的资源
确保有足量多的人才
有最适合公司的人才
快速地进入到公司 快速地发展
这个其实决定了这个船到底是否结实
航向是否是准确的
比如说向内
我需要确保的是组织的稳定性
包括长期的战略方向上的一致性
包括我们整个从上到下的
技术的 产品的研发方向、市场定位
我们的一些市场策略
还有包括战略定位
从上到下大家是有非常完整的认知的
大家是一个非常能打的、灵活作战的团队
我需要保证整体的组织能力
是非常灵敏的 是能够快速去调整的
你上任总裁以来
你对公司接下来三个最重要的发展目标
是什么样子的
我觉得三个方向上的话
首先第一个最重要的方向
一定是产品和技术的创新
因为这个是企业的胜负手的
最基础的一个来源
这个产品和技术的创新
它来自于我硬件层面的优化
也来自于我软件层面的优化
商业化的ROI
可能能够算得过来的一些机会
因为我发现应用场景足够多了
应用场景足够多
它未来产生的一些潜在的需求量足够大
我可能未来就是一个千亿
甚至上万亿GMV的公司
这个时候 我对应地
去做世界模型上面的一些储备
其实它是行得通的
所以在这个方向上
我们长期会保持非常强的战略定力
第二点 还是我们生态的打造
今天我们来到硅谷
可能只是我们整个全球产业生态的第一步
今年我们还会有一系列的
在全球范围内的更多的产业链里面的集会
包括会有更多的每个区域的
重要的合作伙伴的建联
包括一些战略合作或者实际的
应用场景合作的实质性的进展和推动
第三个非常重要的就是专注做全球化
我们也有一个比较强的期待
因为确实现在整个中国的人形机器人公司
在全球范围内还是具备比较强的竞争力的
所以我们也希望能够抓住这波机会
能够快速地在全球各个区域
通过我们比较强的渠道建设能力也好
或者说一些本地化的交付能力也好
快速地去把魔法原子
海外的品牌认知去打透
那IPO呢 IPO是你接下来的目标之一吗
我觉得是这样的
IPO这件事情相对来讲
是一个比较水到渠成的事情
我们现在开始谋求整个IPO
我坦白说
我们现在也在比较紧锣密鼓地
去谋求IPO的计划
就包括我的券商、律所、会所
也都已经进场了
我们整体的方案也论证得比较成熟了
最快我们可能2027年
有一个比较明确的上市的消息
为什么会有这样上市计划
我觉得这个其实也是
确实发展到这个阶段了
不是说我今天看可以
A股或者说港股市场
它上市有什么具体要求
要多少收入 然后要怎么样
我要去硬够这个收入
其实不是这样
反而是因为
我觉得今年 就2026年
我对于整个公司技术层面的升级
包括产品层面快速的收入的放量
我是有比较强的信心的
所以我觉得两方面
一个确实也因势利导
企业发展阶段也还好
同时也确实看到
行业整体IPO的进展都非常快
对魔法原子来讲
我们就变成了一个必须的
同时也很巧合的选择
推动我们比较快速的上市进程
我最后一个问题
在你们的大会上
图灵奖得主Martin Hellman
也会聊到全球协作的重要性
你觉得对于机器人技术
还有机器人领域来说
它是一个需要全球协作的事情吗
在这件事情当中
你觉得中国生态或者中国企业
是占据一个什么样的位置呢
一定是全球协同的
从企业的角度来讲
我觉得魔法原子还是很希望能够接棒
中国企业第四代全球化的浪潮
所以也是为什么今天来到硅谷
至少我们还是抱着一个比较乐观的态度
比较坦诚 开放
也是抱着比较大的善意来的
所以也希望能够在硅谷未来
包括全球化的市场上面
能够吸引到更多志同道合的合作伙伴
好的 感谢Polly
希望之后不管是在国内还是在硅谷
都能看到越来越多魔法原子的机器人
谢谢
以上就是我与魔法原子总裁顾诗韬的对话
整个对话进行了两个半小时
为了大家的观影体验
我们缩减了大约一半的信息
整个采访下来 我觉得是非常有收获的
对整体中国市场的机器人竞争格局
有了更清晰的认知
就像顾诗韬说的
因为硅谷和国内市场
非常不同的创业和资金生态
两边采取的产品路线和发展节奏
都是非常不同的
我们节目平时聊技术路线比较多
但是也希望今天的这场采访
能够带给大家一些不一样的视角
我们的机器人系列还会继续
大家不要忘了关注我们的频道
不要错过更新
好了 这就是这期视频的全部内容
非常感谢大家看到这里
你们的留言、点赞和转发
是支持我们《硅谷101》
做好深度科技和商业内容的最佳动力
我是陈茜 那我们就下期视频再见啦